ينضم الينا في الاستوديو اسامه عيدروس
محلل شؤون السياسيه والعسكريه السودانيه
نبدا معك ايضا بمجرد وحتى قبل انتهاء هذه
الهدنه عادت المعارك الى مستوى نفس
الشراسه ما تفسير ذلك
حتى نصل الى معرفه الصوره الكليه عبد
القادر يعني قبل هذه الهدنه تحرك الجيش
تحركات قبل بدايه الهدنه وبعد نهايه
الهدنه الاولى تحرك الجيش تحركات مهمه
وادخل قوات في اماكن حاكمه في جنوب
الخرطوم وفي ام درمان وفي
الشمال بحري
يعني قوات ضلت مرابطه هناك وكان الناس
يتساءلون اين الجيش اين مشات الجيش من
الدخول في هذه المعارك في المقابل الدعم
السريع اكبر هجوم له كان متزامن قبل
الهدنه السبع ايام بيوم واحد على
الرعاه وعلى المهندسين وعلى وادي سيدنا
وفشل هذا الهجوم المتزامن تحول بعدها
الدعم السريع اليه استراتيجيتو الاولى وهي
الرجوع الى بيوت المواطنين والمرافق
العامه لكن هذه المره بقوه تدميريه هائله
يعني اثناء الهدنه اخلاء مواطنين من
منازلهم سرقه ونهب على مستوى كبير جدا
تدمير دار الوثائق تدمير المتحف القومي او
دخول المتحف القومي والعبث بي وقوه
تدميرها الى كانه هنالك جهه من خارج
السودان توجههم الى ضرب مقدرات الدوله
وانتهى لهم اي هدف عسكري حقيقي في هذه
الاثناء الجيش لماذا هذا الربط بين فكره
ما وصفته الان بدخول لمساكن المواطنين
وهذا المستوى من التدمير ووجود بعد خارجي
في هذه المساله لا يمكن لا يمكن تصور ان
قوه تتحدث عن
الديمقراطيه وحمايه الدوله المدنيه
وانها قامت من اجل الفتره الانتقاليه
واستمرارها فجاه تجد لديها كل هذه القوه
التدميريه لمقدرات الدوله نفسها يعني يعني
ليس هنالك اي هدف عسكري خلال هدنه تم
تنفيذه في نفس الوقت الجيش الذي دخل من
جنوب الخرطوم استطاع ان يعمل عمل نوعي عزل
كل القوه الموجوده حول قناه يعني معسكر
طيبه طبعا المعسكرات نفسها لا يعني لا ليس
هنالك وجود حقيقي داخل المعسكرات لانه يتم
ضربها واستهدافها من الطيران وهي مفتوحه
لكن حول المعسكر نفسه
ومخازن المعسكر كان يتم استخدامها من قبل
الدعم الصجيع بعمليه نوعيه تم تحييد هذا
المعسكر فجاه تحولت العمليات كلها الى
جنوب الخرطوم تذكر الهجوم على اليرموك
والهجوم على المدرعات يعني بدا الدعم
السريع يكثف جهوده نحو جنوب اسامه ما يجري
في الخرطوم لا ينسينا ايضا خطوره ما يجري
في دارفور تحديدا في الجنينه تقارير مخيفه
حتى تربط بينما يجري وما جرى في سنوات مضت
في التجربه الروانديه تقارير عن حوالي 500
شخص قتلوا بينهم اطفال طبعا ومدنيين في
يوم واحد فقط وبالتالي ماذا عن هذا البعد
ايضا وتطوراته
المشاكل في الجنينه ليست جديده يعني ليست
هي صحيح واحده من تمظهرات هذه الحرب
الموجوده في الخرطوم ما يحدث الان في
الجنينه لكن الصراع والمشاكل بين الدعم
السريع
والمكون القبلي المحلي الموجود هناك بدات
من 2019 بعد سقوط النظام السابق وفي يعني
عامين خصوصا عام 2020 تم ضرب مكثف
المدرعات الشجره هذا الامر يعني بالاضافه
لاستنزاف الذي قام به الجيش في الفتره
السابقه لقواته اضعف محطاته الخارجيه من
الذي استنزف الثاني الجيش قام باستهزاف
الدعم السريع عبر عمليات نوعيه عبر ضرب
الطيران عبر
استدراجهم للهجوم الى مناطق محدده تم
الاستنزاف الى درجه انهم الان يركضون
العربات المدنيه الجيش اليوم تحرك في
كماشه يعني كان الناس يتحدثون عن انه سيتم
جرى الجيش لضرب المدنيين في بيوتهم لكن
حركه الجيش اليوم نوعيه وهي في المناطق
الحاكمه وستضع قوات الدعم السريع القماش
محلل شؤون السياسيه والعسكريه السودانيه
شكرا جزيلا لك شكرا